ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Where do you
go to ask Google Cloud
Platform questions?
How do you share best practices?
And how can you
learn from others?
How do you stay up
with the pace of GCP?
In this video, we'll walk
through some prominent
resources and also through
some less obvious ones that
may work well for you
in your GCP journey.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Having the right
resources of information
and using the right
communication channels
can be the difference between a
regular and a highly productive
GCP user.
The good news is you
found this video,
so you're already
on the right path.
It all starts with the
Google Cloud homepage
at the cloud.google.com.
This page remains a reference
for product descriptions
and documentation.
Since many developers identify
themselves by the language
of their choice, we have landing
pages for the most popular
languages supported by GCP, such
as Go, Python, Java, NoJS, PHP,
.NET, Ruby, and Kotlin.
Let's take Go as an example.
The landing page
for Go will walk you
through how to deploy your
web apps using App Engine,
and how to use GCP's idiomatic
Go APIs and libraries.
If you look at
Kotlin, you'll find
quick starts for Compute Engine,
Kubernetes Engine, and App
Engine, as well as
code labs and tutorials
to build auto-scaling
backends for mobile apps,
and instructions for using
your favorite Java and Kotlin
frameworks.
Blog posts are great resources
for both new and seasoned users
to stay on top of GCP.
The main Google Cloud Blog at
cloud.google.com/blog typically
has multiple posts a day, and
covers products, features,
and also partner and
customer stories.
You are probably also interested
in content that is not
exclusively written by Google.
The GCP Medium
publication is a list
of articles curated
by practitioners
for practitioners.
If you'd like to share your
experience with the community,
this is a great
place to be noticed.
This publication also features
a weekly recap of the GCP news
in the last week.
And believe me, there's no
such thing as a quiet week.
If you're into podcasts--
maybe you have a commute
or some other time
to listen to technical
audio content--
then you should
subscribe to at least one
of these two weekly podcasts--
the GCP podcast and
the Kubernetes podcast.
Both of them feature
news of the week
and interviews with
Google engineers,
as well as partners, customers,
and community members.
Since you're watching
this, you may
be interested in more video
content from the GCP YouTube
channel.
We have videos published
here on a regular basis,
and most of them are grouped
into playlists around topics,
products, and events.
There are other several
related YouTube channels,
such as Firebase, TensorFlow,
Google Developers, G Suite,
or Apigee.
If you're hanging
out on Twitter,
you should definitely
follow Google Cloud Platform
@GCPCloud, and
consider also following
one of these active accounts--
Firebase, G Suite Developers,
Google Maps Platform,
Google Open Source,
and again, Apigee.
Several GCP members
monitor these
handles to engage
with the community,
and it can be a great way
to get the team's attention.
Of course, this is
not a replacement
to our support options.
While we're on the
topic of social media,
we also have spaces on Facebook
as well as on LinkedIn.
Check those out.
The GCP community is large,
vibrant, and growing quickly.
It exists online and in a
variety of real-world places,
and this community
landing page covers both.
Community tutorials are
community-contributed how-tos
with an open publishing
process hosted on GitHub.
There are close to
200 tutorials to date.
And if you cannot find what
you're looking for, you should
request it, or maybe even write
something yourself and submit
it.
On the real-world side,
user groups and GCP meet-ups
are great places where
like-minded people meet
to share their experiences,
their best practices, and maybe
even to find a job.
There are active meet-up
groups around the world,
and there should be one nearby.
If not, then create one.
It's easy, and the personal
rewards are numerous.
You can also attend
conferences--
small, medium, or large ones,
such as the one organized
by Google, Google Cloud Next,
or our Summits or onboard events
in dozens of cities
around the world.
You will also find GCP content
in many industry events,
such as OSCON, KubeCon,
Devoxx in Europe,
and of course, in
the more than 600
community-led DevFest events.
In all these events, you
will be able to learn
from technical sessions,
meet with Cloud engineers,
and ask questions.
Getting help from peers can
turn out to be a big asset,
and some of it can
come in the form
of answers on Stack Overflow.
But did you know that
Google engineers maintain
and monitor a number
of GCP-related tags?
This is part of GCP
community support,
and details are documented
in the page mentioned
in the description below.
Of course, there's
always formal support.
And if you're
starting out with GCP,
then I would suggest that
you purchase Silver Level
Support using a portion of
your $300 trial credit right
from the console in
the Support section.
Here's a quick tip.
With a picture being
worth a thousand words,
imagine the value to your
colleagues of a visual
representation of your
GCP architecture made with
great-looking icons and diagrams
from cloud.google.com/icons.
This resource contains
vector graphics, PNGs,
slides, and templates
for popular tools
such as Lucidchart and Draw.io.
And last but not least,
I couldn't leave you
without a cheat sheet,
the Google Cloud Four
Words or Less Cheat Sheet.
The sheet comes in many
different formats, including
several print-friendly formats,
and it is maintained on GitHub.
It's a very popular resource,
and you should definitely
check it out.
As you can see, there are many
options for you to consider.
Pick the ones that
work best for you,
and share anything that you'll
find missing in the comments.
If you like this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward to
more GCP Essentials videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]